And a lot of my talk has already been discussed before, so this should be pretty quick.
So, you know, as it's just been discussed, this degrader basically ubiquitinates the
BTK enzyme, leading to degradation through the proteasome.
And this is done through the E3 ligase.
The, you know, with this approach, you could bypass some of the mutations that are typically
seen with covalent or non-covalent BTK inhibitors, such as C481 or the other mutations, including
474, for example.
This is just some preclinical data.
It showed that, you know, in xenograft models, you get a deep and durable tumor suppression
in wild type, as well as C481 BTK mutated tumors.
This has already been...
Again, discussed.
This is the phase one data.
You know, and when we have...
I have here on the right side, just the summary of the CLL data.
You could see it's very...
You know, these are patients who are very heavily pre-treated.
A lot of them have BTK mutations in 39% of patients.
They've all been exposed to covalent BTK inhibitors, some to non-covalent BTK inhibitors,
BCL2 inhibitors.
So, again, a very heavily pre-treated group of patients.
And...
Responses are, you know, very promising.
So, 85% overall response in this CLL group.
And if you look at the subgroup analysis, you know, there's definitely activity.
For example, like patients who have seen a covalent as well as a BTK inhibitor,
as well as a BCL2 inhibitor, overall response, 93%.
Patients with the BTK mutations, we're seeing an overall response of 77%.
So, again, the agent is definitely very active.
And if you look at the PFS on the right-hand side here,
you could definitely see that those patients with or without BTK mutations
had similar PFS.
The safety profile, obviously, again, these are, you know,
this is still very early in development.
It seems that it has, you know, similar safety profile
to what we typically would see with a BTK degrader.
Although, one thing that we want to keep an eye on is the incidence of neutropenia.
We're seeing a grade 3 or higher.
Neutropenia of 25%.
But, again, you know, this is a very heavily pre-treated group of patients,
and it's not uncommon initially to see, you know,
these patients have issues with bone marrow reserve.
And I think, you know, more data will be needed in subsequent studies.
Also, the infection complications is something to keep an eye on.
There was 12% grade 3 or higher pneumonias here.
So, again, you know, something to keep in mind as the data evolves.
So, it makes a lot of sense to combine.
This agent now with, you know, other modalities.
I think the, you know, one of the interesting concepts would be to combine it
with a BCL2 inhibitor like Sonratoclax, for example,
where basically, you know, you get a deep and strong inhibition of the BTK pathway.
And this would, you know, basically work on the upstream survival signaling.
And at the same time, you know, you would work with a BCL2 inhibitor
to control the, you know, the apoptosis.
And this would, you know, potentially lead to synergy and reduces the, you know,
hopefully at least theoretically reduce the incidence of, you know, a resistance mechanism.
So, the study that I was, you know, that we're currently enrolling on is the 104 study.
Now, this is the combination study combining the BTK degrader with a number of other agents.
So, Sonratoclax, there's an arm with Xanabrutinib, there's an arm with Nosonatuzumab,
you know, it's a big, you know, basically basket trial.
I wanted to, you know, to highlight one of these patients that I saw in clinic
and one of the very first, you know, few patients that we enrolled on the study.
So, basically, this is a 76-year-old lady.
She came in with, you know, CLL.
She was diagnosed in 2009.
She had already pretty much seen everything.
I mean, you know, she's seen back in the day, she's had FCR, BR, Ibrutinib, Venetoclax,
Acalabrutinib, Duvalisib, Pertrabrutinib.
And, you know, she was referred to us to discuss, you know, either a Bispecific or CAR TCL therapy.
And, you know, on the first day of her visit, you know, she was, oh, you know, I've had this, you know,
pretty bad pain in my hip and I can't walk and I'm using a walker for the last two weeks.
It's like, hmm.
So, we imaged it and basically, you know, she had a lot of tumor infiltration in her bones with a pathological fracture.
I told her, listen, I mean, this is probably going to be Richter's.
And, you know, one of the surgeons took her and, you know, she had like fixation and whatnot.
And they obviously took, you know, that big surgical biopsy was not Richter's.
It was just the CLL from hell, basically.
So, we put her on the study.
One more thing.
So, if you look at her genomic profile, so she, of course, has a TP53, not surprisingly.
She's unmutated.
She has the T474 mutation, which would confer resistance to a covalent as well as non-covalent.
She has the covalent BDK inhibitors.
She's refractory dystrophinatic lax, not surprisingly, because she has two BCL2 mutations.
And you could see here, so when it went, you know, when she started, she was transfusion dependent.
She was getting blood and platelets and you could see here the curves for, you know, the hemoglobin and the platelets, you know, they gradually improved over the next few weeks.
You could clearly see, you know, the jump in the white counts, you know, white blood cells, and then it would go down similar to what you would similarly see when you're getting a response
with a BDK inhibitor in these patients.
And the study, you know, for, you know, we don't have PET scans on her, but, you know, we had CT imaging.
And, you know, when she walked in, she had, like, you know, these huge neck lymph nodes and pretty much in two weeks, you know, they pretty much went away.
And you could see here on the images, so she, you know, you could clearly see, you know, accelerated ethnopathy bilaterally, you could see by, you know, retroperitoneal ethnopathy.
And this is her most recent scan three months later, after, you know, starting this, you could clearly see a resolution of, you know, the axillary ethnopathy, as well as the retroperitoneal ethnopathy.
So this is, you know, this is a very active, you know, agent, especially with the potential synergy with other agents like BCL2 inhibition, or, you know, the bispecific data.
So, you know, something to keep an eye on, of course, we have to, you know, just monitor the, you know, the safety of these approaches.
Because again, you know, when you're combining things, you could always, you know, you know, run into issues with, you know, infectious complications and whatnot.
So we'll see how that turns out.
And we're happy to answer any of your questions.
Thank you.